[Music]
in the more you know news writing on a
book submitted by electric town cool
okay I'll take you to sounds like a bad
[ __ ] town I made that one up yeah
dolphins apparently have a clitoris is
that are remarkably similar to you
yard about this you know what dolphins
are the other animals outside of humans
who have sex for pleasure yep pigs too
and they rape I've heard angry they
kidnap yep dolphins and it gained great
them they use it my sex slaves and in
they throw them away
uh-huh I've never seen a dolphin have
sex well you're missing on footage came
into my not huge dicks yeah huge it
comes out like a zebra huge yeah and it
wraps around like a like a tentacle
watch their whole body like a [ __ ]
Star Wars creature dog see the doggy
style but they go around like that yeah
we're gonna huge dicks and they get
puffer fish and they use them as a beach
volleyball and they play with it is that
true finding her that's bullying dude
they [ __ ] with it that's problematic
let me see dolphin penis cuz I put
dolphins having sex and penis I think
marine biologists right now are working
on anti-bullying campaigns for dolphin
they should yeah they should see that
big dick holy [ __ ] I want to see know
about dicks let me tell you you study a
lot of it oh no does that shop it goes
in it wraps around it's a [ __ ]
unicorn under that no that's a normal
when they orgasm it shoots out at like a
really high velocity speed so if a
dolphin rapes you you die what is your
problem
I looked up dolphin rape when I didn't
believe in it okay okay oh that's right
you that's right yeah
can you imagine having a dick that's
half your body size no what is it it's
like a tongue see what is that what is
is this person holding his dick sure
come on it's on it's family this he's
probably like having a good time with a
human touching it that's the killer
whale penis
oh he's stroking it whoa welcome America
that's killer he's trying to empty the
bag probably so doesn't like squirt all
over though be sure to do the back yo
y'all ever seen a duck penis no no that
mash is [ __ ] weird
it's a corkscrew Oh having penises in
like the female search histories that
one's real you like that one's fake this
one's real like the female ducks have
made vaginas that are like corkscrew
also inside them because they like
there's a lot of rapes when it comes to
ducks
yeah David's the right race yeah duck
around nice big gain great wait the
Ducks are [ __ ] up that's why I eat
them yeah that makes sense
I'm more for eating dog Shaffer I'm
gonna get in there they got us like
shirt around like this no the penis
shoots he goes wow I twirled on its own
I think so I mean I haven't seen a lot
of duck penises in real life don't be
like a little girl duck right here and
then like a bunch of boy ducks come up
in and surround her and then a [ __ ]
Reaper they do it for for reproduction
right obviously good not for like
pleasure
they fight over who's chicken gets to be
yeah what they all like try to get her
at the same time dominance but then once
she gets once she gets pregnant they
stick together and they're a couple how
cute bang bang that just sounds like
arranged marriages
though he want her what a tragic way
crawfish are [ __ ] up too Oh
have you guys seen our planet on Netflix
no I don't show me one
I saw watch the Will Smith no that one's
dug two once drained Rock we love that
show no the new one i watch the trailer
it was this one episode about I think it
was in jungles or something but you see
this crazy bird that it like literally
spins it's like black and beautiful oh
that one it was so nice it was like this
like a little yeah he's trying to track
the latest yeah in nature the males have
all these ornate things in like no
females and then girls in I know but in
human life the chicks are hot it's weird
[Music]
these and all the males had fancy
colorful what do you call it not
feathers tail no and in the women were
just fat yeah now they're supposed to
try to fight for the women are being
attracted yeah maybe that's what it used
to be
mm-hmm so many beards instead looks like
intestines the duck is in the duck for
Jana anyway you think ducks feel loved
that's what we're talking about oh sorry
what do you think ducks feel lost [ __ ]
no they're [ __ ] ruthless why not they
rape each other all day we were nicely
the lake was frozen and they had to like
run across the lake to go to another
part that was like melted it was a
funniest cutest thing ever slimy shape
in there but since Tom xrq angry I've
talked about this on decades before
though like when they get in a fight
they're like and then they flap off
their wings and then they're calm again
a lot of animals do that yeah they shake
it off
that's how they shake off their tension
and anger I'd do it all the time you do
do that a lot I can't you know
oh that's why I don't know duck does
that yeah
oh yeah and that's you yes anyway we're
talking about dolphins here
and so they autopsy 11 female dolphins
that died of natural causes and they
dissected their reproductive organs and
created a CT scan of their vaginas
vaginas vaginas they have big clips to
come [ __ ] know so what happens they
found that like human dolphins have a
clitoral hood and two areas of extensive
erectile tissue otherwise why would they
be a [ __ ] for pleasure exactly so and
they're [ __ ] lucky girl they have
their [ __ ] inside their vagina
see that's clutch well but the g-spot
extends to the inside two inches up
there the vagina does it every time
actually the other side of the clitoris
you just gotta buy a vibrator while you
get doggystyle and you're all great I'm
gravy but I'm just saying that's a cool
cuz they don't have hands so it's all
there I picture myself on a Greyhound
bus next to Jill a stranger he turns
over to me halfway through the ride to
Arizona and he's like did you know what
Ducks have big heart sorry unbelievable
you know pigs their orgasm lasts 30
minutes pigs are big dicks two minutes
pigs I hate this I see no hole dude I
ain't made a hole right out on the
internet dude somebody went down the
darkest [ __ ] hole and that's where I
am
look at how long a [ __ ] pig is look
at Pig orgasm what's some bestiality no
what about a Falcons dick I want to see
the Falcons oh no do we just think it's
because we've never seen a penis this
actually big well I've seen big wait
what is it
he's a grower growing these are grown
there's a rat dick
oh [ __ ] no wait what is it things are
usually bigger sensor do you know the
rat dick a snake I don't think so hey
Tiffany yeah hey TIFF can you look up
and see is f a0 zebra Dicky's yeah
that's huge is it stripe though no it's
not no comes out and it Dingles on the
floor I saw this that's disappointing
yeah we want to see if a zebras dick is
straight lobster ball I wanna see now
now it was very important oh it's
actually all black is it like their
tongues if you had a video of you
flopping around our lost a bet I think
it's longer than that - it can touch the
floor
what should small it's probably like
retracting or [ __ ] yeah in the in the
middle of action all of these trust me I
know she is yeah out of all that emotion
that's mine oh that's a baby zebra
though Knicks have two dicks look at
snakes snakes have two days they do
there's no way they have two it comes
out like this also a deeper Zebras dick
matches our tongue and a snake dick
matches say snake penis
why do snakes need two dicks but to [ __ ]
two chicks at one time what do you think
oh there's a snake female snake have two
holes yeah probably
we looked up snake penis can you look up
if polar bears can get hard because it's
really cold a penis and it's just a
bunch of penises yeah weird [ __ ]
yeah can you look up a few large yeah I
can't see oh that's a penis there's two
it gets pushed out wait the side though
well I guess it increases their chances
I got like dick cheese on it I saw it in
Thailand they had a coal brush over and
it may push the penis out of the Cobra
they says very lucky guy has a two penis
and I was like wow I want to see a small
animal that fits in your palm size dude
there's a guy the answer
and the does a mas on reddit that has
two dicks we did a JK news on that guy
okay they feel like this or is that like
this
I think it's side by side do you say
that when he gets hard he's just fat
[ __ ] passes out no he's really stupid
that he like would brag about it he no
brag and say let like girls like turn of
woman's vagina inside out and like one
time this chick he turned her vagina
inside out and she was like well that's
crazy
wait what do you mean she's not dead it
was turned inside out I'd be [ __ ]
screaming and you're like people came in
the hospital maybe it was just like how
your eyelids flip this guy lives in a
porno dude he thinks he's getting jacked
off double D P that's it but he does
yeah really jacked off like this so he
get jacked off and dope and finishing
himself the same time sick too hey tip
what does a bald eagles dick look like
look I couldn't find a decent polar bear
good all-american dick like that
patriotic dick I want it to be prolly
matches this tongue inspiring that's a
national dick right there hmm it's a
protected dick that's nice that's nice
that's like humans dead human dig with
Jeff can you look up what a homeless
guys I've seen too many in LA yeah I
seen a couple really yeah I've seen
homeless [ __ ] yeah I mean that's gross
when you drive by and they're just like
sitting on the sidewalk or the lake
spread I've never seen it it's gross are
seeing this right only my house oh I
gotta clear my [ __ ] search history
now there's a lot of dick
[Music]